and CBS News has learned that the first
victim was the security guard at the
nightclub the first victim that was
killed
cold app and Matt winter strim were
inside the borderline barn grill when
the gunfire started : matter joining us
now we appreciate you joining us
can you describe Col what you were doing
when you first heard the gunshots
we were just standing me and not we're
standing next to each other talking to
some of our friends and I had a line of
sight of the bar and that was what what
I was doing are all of your friends
accounted for
unfortunately not we have not been able
to reach the friends that you were with
that evening yet
most of them that yes but there's a
couple that we're still missing for the
scene inside the bar it was before
happened it's just a normal Wednesday
night just it happened a good time and
as soon as it all started it just went
to utter chaos real quick how did you
try and hide yourself and your friends
and ultimately escape we both tried to
get as many people behind cover as we
could I was next to an exit that exits
out on to a patio where people smoke and
when I went out there there was a bunch
of people out there who had no idea that
anything was going on because they were
away from the noise and I told all of
them to hop the fence and get out of
there and Matt what was going through
your mind and what was your reaction
once you started hearing it did you
recognize this for what it was the
minute it started when I when I heard
the first shots
I knew exactly what was going on
gunshots aren't something that you you
mistake for anything else they're very
distinct noise I looked I looked
immediately up to where the noise was
coming from and I I saw the shooter he
was a tall dark figure probably 6-2 6-3
and he was pointing a handgun over the
counter towards the workers that were
working there and just started firing
and so my instinct kicked in and I had
to save my family and friends we had to
make sure that we got as many of them
out of there as possible so we we
dropped to the floor hid underneath
a pool table until I heard the first
round of shocks cease and we figured
that that was the end of his magazine at
least that he had run out of bullets to
fire and at that point I looked to my
left and I saw that someone had thrown
one of the barstools through the window
to create an exit and so I grabbed the
nearest bar stool that was next to me
and threw that through and
and probably four other guys began
shuffling men and women and people as
young as 18 out of the out of the back
windows into the embankment below just
so that we could get everyone out of
there
and just keep as many of us safe as
possible so your instinct mat was not
just to run and get out of there
yourself but to help the others who are
who were also still inside yeah these
these these people that we were here
with this is our family : I both come
here
weekly
we've known a lot of these people for
upwards of 10-15 years we've grew up
with them and so it's not it's not
something where you just get out of
there and fend for yourself that's what
can I do to protect as many of my
friends as possible because my my life
is is taken care of I know where I'm
going when I die
so to give my friends and my family the
chance to live another day that's I want
nothing more than that so we did what we
had to do to get out of there that is so
great and so selfless of you and we're
so sorry that you had to experience that
on a night when you just wanted to have
fun with your friends
Cole and Matt we hope that you reunite
with all of your friends that all of
them are safe and sound thank you so
much